hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday October
16th 2023 I almost said August oh my God
what a [__] faux paw that would have
been I would have to erase 17 seconds
and start all over again but isn't that
what life is
about you know just acknowledging that
you may made a mistake and taking the
time to
stop go back and fix what it is guys
guys let's all just make a promise to
ourselves that when we make mistakes the
first thing we do is we forgive
ourselves what' you do if
this if this became this is what the
podcast became you know that's like a
that's a big [__] you know celebrity
move is when you know whatever the [__]
it was you were doing isn't making any
[__] money anymore what is the
[__] move you start giving advice to
complete strangers like you give a [__]
about
them guys I just want you know I just
wanted to take a
moment outside my big white [__]
Mansion you know those big stupid white
boxes indoor outdoor living open space
so [__] stupid who the [__] what do
they call now indoor outdoor living and
then it's like uh uh not open space I
forget
now open floor
plan it has an open floor plan look over
here's where you make cookies and while
you do that you can watch somebody
[__] watching TV it's like I like the
walls all right open floor plan is great
wait until you have a fight with your
wife and then you just can't get away
from her I mean walls save
marriages you gotta [__] can't just
have her looking at you just hating
everything about you staring at the back
of your head she's out in the kitchen
right she just starts thinking like what
if I just [__] there's a skillet
right over there what if I just grabbed
it walked over whacked him on the
[__]
head all right threw the skillet in the
Ravine there's always a ravine whenever
somebody who's never killed somebody
before when it's a crime of passion
there's there's either a ravine a crawl
space or some sort of uh trunk I've
learned that when my wife watches the
murder shows before she goes to bed you
know which is kind of a hacky premise at
this point but she she hasn't been doing
it
lately but anyway let's get just back to
this guys I just want you to know that
you're special
just think about that you're unique you
have something to say You're
beautiful yeah that's just you know just
take that and start your [__] week
working for these greedy ass [__]
corporations
um we are at the end of capitalism here
in America I can tell you that it's the
beginning of the end and it's going to
get [__] hostile and the genius is is
the the CIA runed Fox News and CNN will
have us fighting each other that's going
to be the genius of this Rebellion The
Genius of this Rebellion is two people
with different colored ties with the
same dick in their ass are going to be
fighting each
other thinking that the dick belongs to
the other person and it doesn't it
doesn't oh Bill what are you doing dick
in the ass
[__] what would you call this
algorithm you know I used to think that
that's what like the genius of racism
was was anybody who like this is the
deal if any if you can be if they can
get to
you all
right as a white person if they can get
to you you're you're not as white as you
think you
[Laughter]
are you are you're like uh
uh I don't know I don't know how to put
it it's like you're not going to get to
the people that are really [__] you
over that was the deal I I can't
remember I've been doing this [__] for
so [__] long but like I just saw
something I reposted it on the Instagram
grams there someone was saying that the
[__] senate or house whatever the
[__] it is pass something to be voted on
it's not a thing yet but there is
legislation to allow 15 and 16 year olds
to work in like meat packing the
Superstores all of these people people
that treat adults like [__] it's just
brilliant evil so now what's going to
happen is is the the parents of the kid
the kid is now going to take the mom or
the Dad's
job okay so they don't have to pay them
and then that's going to make these
people have a difficult time making
their [__] mortgage so then they got
to sell their [__] house and then the
corporation that's buying up all the
houses will then swoop in and have an
even easier time making a cash offer and
selling it
and where are all of these [__]
politicians they don't say anything
nothing with a blue tie or a [__] red
tie is GNA say a [__] thing about it
but that Fringe candidate man who's just
out of his mind and is going to ruin the
election do you know what [__]
dumbass Hill I'm on a [__] thing here
I'm on a [__] thing here right
because there's a candidate that's in
this election and he was actually
calling out corporations For What the
the [__] they were doing and then
magically he immediately gets branded uh
a a [__] antivaxer and [__]
anti-semitic all right and here's the
thing let's go with that let's say he
is let's say he's anti-semitic let's say
he's an anti [__] vaxer let's say he
[__] jerked off in somebody's face in
the park let's say he did all of those
things all
right fine here's my question the other
[__] he's talking about
how come nobody else is talking about
that stuff how about how come nobody in
a blue tie nobody in a red tie is
talking about what these [__]
corporations are doing why does dumbass
Hillary Clinton say stupid [__] like if
Donald Trump wins that will be the end
of democracy you know what I mean just
feeding you this [__] lie that if you
vote for the right colored tie that this
[__] that these corporations are
doing is somehow going to stop it isn't
it
isn't it's not going to stop until you
pick up a [__] ax handle and you
start swinging at the right skulls you
know what I'm
saying no those days have come and gone
at this point they they literally have
R2D2 driving down the street delivering
[__] food and it somehow gets there
and people eat it and they're okay with
it you know I took my lovely wife out
for ice cream today and I just watched
this woman in front of me where for some
reason she's punching in like the tip
and all that and then for whatever
[__] reason she gives the salt and
the shake [__] her phone number it's
like what what the [__] do they need
your phone number
for these young people grow up with such
a lack of [__] privacy that they
don't even understand what the [__] it
is they're doing and I'm just watching
each one of them just
[__] they're all right with it
they're all right with it you know and I
bet when I was their age I bet there was
someone my age looking at me with
whatever the [__] I was all right with
and it's been this slow gradual [__]
thing you know I mean if you look at the
greed in my business right now that led
to this
strike um just this out ofc control
[__] greed the same
way they like I was talking to my buddy
about like all this labor [__] like they
literally want to go back to the
Industrial Revolution which is why
unions ended up coming about and they
had kids like [__] 8 years old
working in there and these robber barons
who are some reason glorified were
taking all of this [__] money and it
was this
unbelievable level of read but the
problem with them back then was they
were celebrities and people knew who the
[__] they were Andrew Carnegie JP Morgan
the Vanderbilts the Rockell they were
names they were like [__] celebrities
and like smart Mobsters they didn't want
to be in the papers unlike that Canary
[__] suit wearing guy yellow like
everybody looks at [__] Al Capone the
reason why you know Al Capone is because
the [__] guy was in the papers and
all those other gangsters look at him
like he was a [__] idiot that's the
story that's never been told in these
Hollywood movies as they [__] glorify
that guy all of the the smart Mobsters
looked at him like he was a [__]
idiot and he was [__] himself and
[__] everything that they were doing
and all the smart Mobsters what they
were trying to do was go legit not that
they were going to be honest people they
wanted to go legit so they could get on
the legal side of stealing which is what
corporations do what they do is legalize
stealing if you're on the other side
with the mob you're stealing you have to
hide the money you got to drive a lesser
car you get on the legal side of
stealing you can drive a shiny car right
down the [__] Street like I got a
buddy of mine they're [__] with his
pay
right this is how corporations do it but
he you know he can get a lawyer because
they agreed for the money so what they
do is they give you equity in the
company company and the second you have
equity in the company you can no longer
like I guess for whatever reason like
barter for your salary and then they can
cut your pay and be like well well
you're one of the owners so it's really
and they give you like a morsel of
ownership so I was going well why don't
you not sign it it's like they like
forced him to sign this [__] and then
this is what they do so then they they
cut your pay in half they save the
company all this money and then in the
end the [__] that did it to you write
themselves a bonus at the end of the
year a bonus for
what they just took half your salary and
then [__] gave it to yourself and
they just label it as a bonus they say
that you're an owner it's just
completely out of control and nobody is
[__] doing anything about it anything
about it and anytime some politician
comes along and says hey maybe we should
do something about this they immediately
vilify the person say that they're a
communist a socialist a fringe [__]
blah blah blah and then all these
[__]
chips who [__] vote red tie or blue
tie tell you that it's a waste of a
[__] vote blows my [__] mind blows
my [__] mind oh Billy's Soap
Box Billy's on his Soap Box
he heard a couple of things he clicked
on a website and now he's running his
Yap
um
anyway no I feel like we're coming to
the end of this [__] like at some like
at some
point it's either just going to become
total tyranny like a [__]
dictatorship or it's going to be uh I
don't know it's going to kind of be
something else I will tell you this I've
been in countries where there's
dictators it's not as bad as they
say you know I just thought like you're
just getting the [__] kicked out of you
the whole time but it's not like
that it's like you
know countries I've been in where
there's like a dictator the vibe is
Dad's
home that's what the vibe is Dad's home
so you better be on your p's and q's you
can still [__] enjoy yourself just
don't get too [__] loud you know
know just don't piss off
Dad um that is the vibe so I don't know
what direction we're going in but like
just the [__] level of
greed that is just I is just so wildly
out of control and um I know you guys
probably think I'm nuts I don't
literally think the CIA controls Fox
News and CNN but if you notice just like
politicians career politicians they
don't bring up the greed of corporations
in any sort of of of effective
manner all right they might sort of
loosely talk about it or whatever right
like CNN and [__] was like where where
where are these [__] stories you know
what I mean they don't give a [__]
right but if somebody who's on a TV show
says the wrong [__] thing or uh you
know somebody [__] goes into a
7-Eleven and takes a [__] on a counter
well it's unbelievable what the [__] you
know like that makes the [__] news
look you know you obviously
somebody here's my like why do I need to
know that that happened yeah I
understand that there's [__] crazy
people in the world but what about the
real lunatics huh what about those
people oh Bill shut up you know what it
is I didn't watch any football
today I didn't watch anything I my my
lovely wife uh had a gig and she was
gone for like 3 or 4 days I missed her
terribly and I was like what do I want
to at the end of my life am I when I'm
laying in my deathbed am I going to
think like you know I I missed the fifth
week of foot football six week of
football you know instead of hanging out
with her you know and you know what
ended up happening we went out what the
[__] did we
do we went somewhere and did something
we want to get something to eat and then
she said hey you want to go to go to a
cigar bar watch you know I got you know
I got to put some of this footage
together I was like all right ended up
smoking a cigar and I watched a little
bit of the uh the Rams Cardinals game
and I gotta tell you that backup
quarterback that uh the Cardinal had was
very impressive I mean he's got a young
team and they made a lot
of errors and stuff but I thought he was
throwing a good ball he was showing
leadership qualities and I got to tell
you something you know being a fan of
the Pats I'm sitting there going like
hey I like this guy just say it not
trying to cause any QB I mean what am I
talking about he would come there and
he'd have to run for his [__] life
too um I guess the Pats look better I
don't know how it works on YouTube
which by the way I'm still [__]
pissed that the NFL made a deal with
[__] YouTube not that they made the
deal that they sold it to you like yeah
you don't have to put a dish on your
house well you didn't [__] say that
20 years ago you [__] when you made
everybody put a dish on their house now
you're [__] turning around don't do
the Saddam Hussein like yeah this is our
guy and then 10 years later what the
[__] is up with this guy he needs to be
stopped what do you mean he was in the
band he was in the [__] band dude if
you look at the America's foreign policy
it's it tracks if you watch a
documentary on the band uh Eagles not
the Eagles Eagles same [__] thing the
amount of [__] people in and out of
that goddamn band in and out and in and
out [__] this guy's in everybody
loves him now this guy's not talking to
this guy and [__]
B that's how we are yeah this guy yeah
this guy he's a [__] Ally we love
this guy got to be stopped it's got to
be
stopped um oh I'm all over the map um so
anyway we ended up going and I went to
this cigar
bar and I smoked a little nub and I just
watched some of the game had a great
time and then uh oh yeah I took my wife
off for ice
cream and uh that's when I saw the lady
with the phone number I was just like
why the [__] are you giving them your
[__] phone number why would you do um
but anyway I had been on the road for
like 10 days 11 days doing that bus
thing and my wife was going to be out of
town and I just said [__] it I'm just
going to stay home for the week I did do
the I did the the jam in the van
Thursday night um to raise money for the
people out there in
Hawaii which by the way you know when
[__] like that
happens you know how come we don't
[__] just immediately just help those
people you know how come how come we
don't do that you know why there's no
[__] money in it there's no money in
it if we didn't own
Hawaii if we didn't already Annex Hawaii
we then would have been like we need to
go in and help these people and we're
not helping them we would go in and just
take it it's how it works and once they
take it then they don't give a [__]
about
you gloom and doom that's what I'm
pitching this week um
sorry um yeah so coming up next week I'm
going to
uh I'm going to do a little bit of
flying today was like the perfect
[__] day too I will tell you that it
was the perfect [__] day but as I
mentioned I'm trying to get um double
the amount of solo hours I've gotten in
the first 10 years of flying which is a
pitiful sum and uh only need a few more
hours to do it but
um this has been my best year other than
the year I went to try to get my
instrument and then we sold the movie I
sold a script for a movie that um I had
to make so then I couldn't [__]
complete that that bugs me two things in
my life bugs me is flunking French as
much as I did and never learning the
language and not getting my instrument
rating those the only two things other
than that everything worked out um oh I
got a funny story for you you know when
I was going on
uh right I was about ready to go on
stage in Springfield
Massachusetts um my daughter called me
six years old she calls me up I'm like
what's up buddy and she goes
Dad she goes why why do you play a bad
guy in the
Mandalorian and I laughed I go why he's
not really a bad guy she and she was
like my friend at school said you play a
bad guy in the Mandalorian why why do
you play a bad guy dad why and I was
like well my character is not really bad
at first you think he's bad but then you
see on the next one you know he's not
that bad and then she goes yeah but why
dad
why why would you play a bad guy I was
like well I I don't write it you know
what I mean I'm an actor and I just kind
of
do what what they tell me to do she goes
did you play a bad guy in Star Wars and
I said no I wasn't in Star Wars that was
a long time ago and she goes all right
well then I'm literally they're giving
my
intro then well then why do
you play a bad guy on the Mandalorian
and I finally just said look you GNA
have to ask John Fabro because you know
I didn't write this
stuff and she goes all right I said okay
I got to go on stage and she said all
right I go I love you I hung up and I
went up on
stage and I I think I did like I don't
know I did like 20
minutes and it was going great and
everything but in the back of my head I
was thinking like why does she care
whether I play a bad guy maybe she just
thinks that makes me a bad person I have
no idea but the
questions that she's starting to ask is
um it's
incredible and every few months like
that the way that they change and you
just think like oh okay my son's like
this and my daughter's like that and
then all of a sudden it flips it's been
a
uh it's been quite a uh an amazing
experience and um I don't know I got a I
got a gig coming up in Reno on October
28th I'm going to be there with Joe
bartnik and I got to tell you guys I am
having the best [__] shows of my
career and it's because of that busz
tour I just decided like if I have to do
my Act 10 times in 11 days I am going to
get so [__] sick of it so I just
started riffing and improving kind of
trying to avoid my Act and the game is
avoid the ACT until I'm not killing and
if I'm not killing then I just do a joke
from my
act because people paid money not to
watch me [__] around right and um I kind
of took that into I did two
shows for the uh Hawaiian benefit there
Thursday night for a
metaed and
um I went up and
did a set on the first show and then on
the second show I tried to do as little
material as I did on the first show and
I did 45 minutes roughly on both shows
and I just could
not have I could not have had a better
time and if there's any comedians
listening to this I kind of shut off
that voice that said don't say that I do
make a quick judgment call if it's going
to come off as like ignorant in any sort
of way that I don't want to [__]
you
know I I just want to make sure that I'm
that it it's all coming off as [__]
jokes you know so
sometimes you know I do say all right I
shouldn't say that don't say that but
the stuff that I was saying I don't
remember half the [__] I was
saying I remember one point I was
riffing and somehow I talked about the
clan and said it was a bowling league
that went wrong or something like that
and I remember laughing about it the
next morning going that doesn't even
make sense
there weren't any bowling
leagues in the [__] 1890s
right I have no
idea I don't even know what the [__] I'm
talking about right now I'm wiped out
cuz the second I got home after hanging
out with the first kid I always call my
wife my first kid so I hung out with
her and uh we had a great time and then
I came home
and my daughter was immediately like
okay Dad where are we going I go what do
you mean where are we going it's like 4
in the afternoon she said dad you said
after you hung out with Mom you were
going to do something with me and I was
like oh [__] and I was like all right
what do you want to do and she's like I
want to go this you know this freaking
place all you
know I don't know like 10 [__] blocks
away or something like that I was like
look I just got home can we do something
at home then I had to deal with that
next thing anyway we go out in the
backyard and I started throwing her some
you know pictures and she's got the
batch went up she got a Red Sox jersey
and stuff and
uh she's crushing
it just crushing it and uh we had like
the best time and I got this killer
glove that somebody gave me like I'm
actually a right I throw right-handed
but when I messed up my right shoulder I
just kind of Miss throwing a ball so I
just started throwing Lefty so I can
kind of do it a little bit and this
glove that somebody got me cuz they saw
me throwing Lefty it's a left-handed
glove it's this beautiful
Rawlings that's like all black oh my God
it is [__]
gorgeous and um I always felt Rawlings
made the best gloves I had a Wilson When
I was a kid believe it or not I had a
Wilson that was signed you know they did
like the stamp signings it was Ron gidry
the gator the guy who won the one game
playoff game in 1978 well my my dad
wasn't like the
biggest I can't say he wasn't a big
sports fan he just had a ton of kids so
he was at work so I don't think he
noticed he just grabbed a [__] glove
kind of amazed that they sold it in
Massachusetts but this is these are the
days before [__]
ESPN and [__] and things really got
ramped up and plus she played baseball
in it like a couple of weeks it got so
dirty you couldn't see the signature um
but some buddies of mine had like those
Rawlings gloves and I always remember I
felt the leather was just a little bit
it was a like higher quality like softer
they always had that that option you
could have your finger outside the glove
love I never knew if that was to make it
so you could squeeze it easier or it's
like you know the ball had a tendency of
Sting in your index finger um but
anyways whatever this glove is it's just
a [__] it's a masterpiece and I still
haven't even broken it in and
um had a great time doing that and then
uh we went down and got a uh a family
photo in front of something that I can't
promote um that I'm very proud of and
I'm hoping this [__] strike will be
over
soon I hope these greedy [__] people
can just be happy with taking 90 [__]
percent of everything they won't they
won't so [__] talks broke down again
according to my union sag they literally
came back
essentially you know everybody thought
when the
writer thing was solved that the actors
would be next
and uh that's not how it worked I guess
they came back to the table with
essentially what they offered at the
beginning which caused the strike or
whatever caused them to strike so
they're really just trying to like break
the union it's just such a [__] sad
thing just watching this level of
greed you know you just want to be like
dude how big does your house have to be
how many zeros have to be after your
[__] name before you feel like you
won like how much do people like not
like how miserable do they have to be
living versus how you're living for you
to make it feel so you can like feel
something they're like [__]
sociopaths like I can be honest with you
I don't get what is the point of making
money if you're not trying to help
somebody out why would you like make
money you know to like [__] hurt
other people it just [__]
boggles the
mind you know but it just is what it is
and just the way the whole [__] game
is set up I was telling you guys that
last week I just last time I podcast I
in this [__]
business I I anytime I'm at a fork in
the road should I do this or should I do
that it's always like my gut saying this
is the right thing to do but this over
here is more money and I don't think
I've ever been involved in a situation
where doing what's
right or making more money
it's always that it's never do the right
thing and make more money it's always
like do the right thing or make more
money and I think it's the people that
go or make more money they're the ones
that sort of Ascend the corporate ladder
but on my side of the ball if I do that
do the right thing or make more money if
I do that if I choose or make money then
I just become like everything just kind
of falls
apart and you get like Overexposed and
you a [__] cheeseball and you know
you you took the bag as the kids say and
then everybody's [__] sick of you or
whatever you did you know you chose more
money to do some piece of
[__] and then it tanks and then they go
well that's because of you you [__]
piece of [__] you're like oh man I
should have done I should have done this
other thing over here that paid way less
because it ended up coming out good I
just don't understand it maybe it's that
biblical thing where they say money is
the root of all evil I don't
know there's a lot of [__] dumb
decisions that you can make out there
and you know you know how I know that
people you know I know that cuz I
[__] made them all
there um I've taken the
money I've done that I have taken the
money I never did it I don't think I've
done it really in the acting thing but I
definitely did it in standup and I paid
every single [__] time you want to do
a comedy club or do you want to do a
private gig that pays way more money
I'll do the private gig and you go there
and it is a
[__]
nightmare [__]
nightmare [__] nightmare I remember
the worst one I ever did I agreed to do
this [__] Christmas party I think it
was was the second to last the last two
gigs I did I did a Christmas party for
these [__] rich
[__] on the Upper East Side in like the
[__]
basement of somebody's
uh like
[__]
townhouse on like the Upper East Side
they basically had a [__] house I
mean it was I think that's why I said
yes to the gig wasn't even the money
when you live in New York City you live
in such a small space for so much money
you become obsessed with other people
people's Apartments
obsessed even people at your level cuz
you want to see like well what does
theirs look like how are they doing it
like what are the shops in this
neighborhood like you're never happy
with wherever the [__] you live in in
New York because it's just it is what it
is right so these people had a [__]
house you know right off of Fifth Avenue
and I was just like I want to see what
the [__] what does it look look
like and cuz I don't know about you guys
if you ever lived in New York City after
a while those brownston you're just
walking by and this this weird thing
where it's just like what is that like
and then
simultaneously you're like what's to
stop some lunatic from just your front
door is right [__] there that's what
I kind of liked about apartment living
was if some psycho came
in I mean they got to get through two
doors the
super you know they got to take flights
of
stairs and by the time they get up to my
[__] fifth or sixth floor walk was I
fifth floor walk up I had a fourth floor
walk up and a fifth floor walk
up I was just like by the time they
[__] get to me he's the [__] dude
is going to be so exhausted from killing
people or somebody would have screamed
loud enough that maybe the cop you feel
like safe those [__] Brownstones you
can't even use the first
floor what are you going to be doing
sitting there in the [__] window
smoking your pipe next to a fire is all
these other people that don't have as
nice apartment are walking by going look
at this [__] cozy [__] my favorite
English
expression you [__] cozy [__]
um but anyway so I took the [__]
gig and they actually gave me a tour of
the place it was kind of funny that
place was also like a walkup I don't
think maybe there was an El elevator I
don't remember but I just remember there
was these like long ass [__]
staircases and I can't even remember how
many floors there were but the [__]
place was so big I performed in their
backyard oh wait a I'm combining
gigs yeah no that wasn't that
gig that one went
okay no it was a [__] Christmas party
and it was in the same part of New York
Upper East Side
and I went in and nobody there knew I
was going to be there and they all were
having a good [__] time and then I
went up in a defensive mode because I
had done enough of those [__] things
to know that it was going to suck so
rather than being like a relief pitcher
and forgetting about the Home Run I just
[__] gave up I came up there thinking
about my last batter which was my last
private gig and I went up there oh my
god oh it was a legendary
bombing and then I tried to lash out and
I'm going you know what the [__] is
wrong with you guys and they that didn't
work and it just everything that I said
I was just anytime I supposed to go
right I went left and the other way I
just kept going down and down and down
and I was standing there and then even I
started to hate the sound of my voice
which that whole [__] crowd did the
second I got on stage and I just
remember thinking like I have to do a
half hour or I don't get paid and I was
15 minutes in and from 15 minutes
on I actually agreed aged with the crowd
that's what I should have
said I said you know what I actually
agree with you silence like this was
just a bad [__] idea but if I said
that I wouldn't have got [__] paid
but what I wanted to say was like I you
know what I thought you guys were
[__] but now I actually understand that
I'm the [__] that came in and ruined
your Christmas party you didn't need me
you were hanging out you were laughing
you were having a good [__] time and
then I came in and interrupted all of it
okay I am a [__] okay however in defense
the [__] that's hosting this party hired
me so you should be mad at this person
too um sorry bit of a long story
but I'm going a I don't know I had a
great day I I know I don't wear all this
[__] I think this is just [__] that I
saw during the week that I that I found
disturbing so then I what I do is I just
[__] shut off the all TVs probably I
didn't even watch the [__] football
today I was just like I'm just going to
spend time with my family with whatever
time we have
left
in this [__] country which is
obviously an
overreaction but uh you know that [__]
when it's just raining down on you it
does become [__]
overwhelming so I don't think I'm 100%
uh in the wrong um anyway well let's do
some advertising here people what do you
say there oh I gambled again this
[__] week with the bed MGM and I went
two and two
again all right I only two games over
500 I've gone two and two every single
week I picked four games on the anything
better podcast with one of my favorite
people in the world Paul
verie and uh I've gone two and two every
single week except one week I went three
in one so inexplicably I am two games
above 500 and I have yet to have a
losing week although I've only had one
winning week all right
I ain't really winning but I ain't
losing Oh Billy middle of the road I've
been called a
Centrist a freckled [__] Centrist all
right simp Simply Safe
everybody well it's official fall is
here if you're like me you're settling
back into business routines uh with the
kids at school and Spare Time filled
with soccer practices and seasonal
activities your home may be sitting
empty and vulnerable that's why I
recommend Simply Safe dude I recommend a
[__] gun turret on top of your house
at this point uh Simply Safe home
security and their revolutionary home
monitoring Innovation 24/7 L live guard
protection it's designed to help stop
crime in real time now if an intruder
breaks into your home Simply Safe
professionals monitoring agents can
actually see speak to and deter them
through simply safe's new Smart Alarm
alarm Wireless indoor camera 24/7 live
guard protection is made possible by the
new Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera
available with a fast protect monitoring
plan the new Smart Alarm indoor camera
is the only indoor security camera that
can trigger the alarm and instantly
deter Intruders with a built-in siren it
has a why don't they have like [__]
some Batman Spider-Man
[__] you know you got to have like a
giant net they come walking
in they trip the alarm and then the
[__] net brings them up and they they
uh something happens well you know what
you do you go to one of those old uh
Vietnam war
vets the Viet Kong you get them the them
they they figure they got some bamboo
[__] that comes flying around the corner
and just impales
you you know that's what they that's
what the [__] should happened they're
going into your [__] house they
should they should come out feet first I
mean that's the American way whatever
but you know I think Simply Safe is
gradually moving towards deadlier
ways um anyway it has a privacy shutter
to provide protection when you need it
and privacy when you want it when you're
begging your wife there uh 247 lifeguard
protection and the new Smart Alarm
indoor camera Works seamlessly as part
of the Simply Safe system to help your
whole home safe keep your whole home
safe from break-ins fires floods and
more install your way do it yourself in
about 30 minutes or have a Simply Safe
expert set it up for you you know at the
end of this read I'm going to give you
my my ideal home security system if I
was running it install it your way do it
yourself in about 30 minutes or have a
Simply Safe expert do it for you either
way it's easy to protect your home for a
limited time get 20% off your new system
when you sign sign up for fast
protecting protect monitoring visit
simply safe.com bur that's s p
sf.com bur there's no safe like Simply
Safe um all right this would be my
ultimate if I was going to break into
the uh the home
security racket you know you got people
like simply safe out there you got you
got you get I I don't know who else you
got out there you got people but they've
been doing it see when you go out you
try to establish a new
brand sorry had to get that yawn up I
was going to fight it I said no [__]
let it out um you got to make a big
splash you know what I
mean what like the old [__] car
companies what would they do they'd
redesign the car they get some [__]
laying on the [__] Hood like that was
going to be your
life steady you [__] stuck in
bumper-to-bumper traffic in the rain
wearing your McGruff [__]
raincoat the goddamn slacks on right
they don't show that all right so I
would make a big splash this is what I
would
do I would hire uh Special Forces from
this country and and a Viet
Kong guy veteran from the from from the
Vietnam War right I figured he's like in
his 80s but from what I heard over there
they don't stand when they don't stand
around they squat down which is
according my Instagram videos that's
supposed to be
great for you to live longer so I'm
thinking enough of them are still
alive and you
combine these Special Forces here with
the Viet Kong old school way of doing it
you go down to Home Depot
right you come up with some things that
just end this person and then we install
these things in your [__] house
which I'm sure wouldn't be unsettling at
all if that wasn't unsettling enough
then what we do don't you see is we go
out back and we dig an not a six foot we
dig an 8 foot
grave okay cuz the cops whatever the
[__] they have when they're looking I
think whatever it is it only goes down 6
feet you dig an 8 foot [__] grave
that is ready to go you put the steel
[__] plates over it all right so when
somebody comes in when you're down the
street at the [__] Olive Garden and
you're on your second bread basket and
those [__] bamboo come around the
corner and just [__] impale them
right then what's going to happen oh you
use deadly force we got to fill out a
[__] report no you don't no you don't
nobody even heard
it okay somebody thought you dropped a
tray of dishes not even dishes You
Dropped a [__] a laptop or something
they're not even going to hear it they
have surround sound next door you
[__] impale this [__] then you come
back all right and we'll give you like
it almost looks like the jaws of life
but it isn't it's the jaws of no life
and you pull this person
off
okay we will erase the video of
everything that happened at which point
we then become accomplices in this
[__] murder so you know I can't say
anything you can't [__] say anything
you take the body you remove the [__] no
wait we'll come over we'll help you
[__] pick it up and then we will
[__] dump that [__] down
there will'll pour the breaking bad
chemicals over the person maybe we do
that you stick them in the barrel they
turn into nothing and then we pour the
gelatinous that [__] that was them down
into an 8ot hole and then we [__]
bury it and then what you do is you put
a planter box over it right maybe that's
a dead
giveaway I don't think so ah planter
box no you got to go
grass we'll go grass we'll put a planter
box some somewhere else in your yard as
a
misdirection and then that's it you hose
it
off you hose the floor
off we have Harvey kitel come over the
cleaner we clean the whole [__] thing
up and it's [__] over and you still
have whatever the [__] it is you're into
nobody got to your DVD collection it's a
little
dark you know all right I'll give you
that it's a little [__] dark um well
[__] uh I'm going a little goth this
week no
um all right yelling about sports Bill
why do you think it is that you're
always yelling about
sports well because I [__] enjoy
them you
know all your teams won in your lifetime
but everywhere I turn you're still
yelling at people about
football what would it say what would it
take for you to say fair
enough oh you know what I don't is there
anything worse than somebody passive
aggressive okay this is one or two
things either your teams aren't winning
or my team beat your team or the Wild
Card you don't even you don't even like
sports what would it talk for you uh
okay what would it take for you to say
fair enough I would have to lose all
passion for watching
football I love
football all right and what you consider
yelling I consider a fun back and forth
that that's all we do is yell at each
other and talk about that and we have a
good [__] time I'm sorry it bothers
you you know I don't like that you're
wording this in a way that you actually
care about my
happiness you know um I'll tell you
what's funny is everywhere I turn I
don't see myself yelling about sports
because I don't watch videos of myself
so maybe that that's that's what you
should do I have a I'll answer your
question with a question when are you
going to stop watching me yelling about
Sports if everywhere you
turn I love that everywhere I turn
everywhere you turn I want to make some
toast oh there's Bill bur yelling about
sports no you're clicking on these
[__] videos stop clicking on them go
watch somebody else then you can watch
him [__] yelling about how I can't
believe this guy's playing Luke
Skywalker or uh oh my God what year do
we live in that you can't [__] do X Y
and Z as a you
know you know I can't believe they don't
recognize this person as the greatest
home run hitter in women's sports
hitting 700 home runs you know when they
were a guy last week she is a woman blah
blah you can [__] yell about that
right you got you have the [__] that you
yell about stop acting like you're not a
[__] human being all right when am I
going to stop yelling about sports never
just like every other sports fan never
I would love to be at a point of like
well I've seen all my teams win it you
know but then I have kids and I want
them to see it you know so I mean what
what do you want from me I never claimed
to be
smart go listen to Neil degrass
Tyson that [__] I love that [__]
guy you know just blows people's [__]
minds no scientist has ever said you
know I got to tell you something that
Neil de Tyson
woo nobody Nobody Does it Like That Just
the way the man looks through a a
[__]
microscope
um I mean Neil de crash Tyson going
around and talking to non-scientists
about science it's that's got to be like
a [__] kids party for him he's making
like balloon
animals I want to see I I keep saying
this I want to see Neil Drass Tyson sit
down with another scientist and have
that guy legit be like wow Neil I never
looked at it that
way okay stop talking to dummies like me
who could who were good at math until
about 7th or eighth grade obviously
you're gonna blow my [__] mind all
right sports fan old dad
Billy uh I'm a 24y old man with a
lifelong passion for sports hey I'm
right there with you uh over the years I
amassed an impressive collection of
sports jerseys oh boy now what are you
gonna do with them I've always enjoyed
sports gear but recently I've started
feeling self-conscious about wearing
jerseys in public it somehow feels
childish to me
congratulations congratulations yeah
that's that's age appropriate look at
you maturing like a normal person you
know you're 24 according to Neil degrass
Tyson and scientist at 2 it takes 25
years for the brain to fully form all
right yeah dude you're 24 you're and you
said I'm a 24 year old man key word
there you're a man you can grow a
mustache okay unless you're playing in
the league what the [__] are you doing
walking around wearing a
jersey I mean I think you can get away
with it at your age because you're the
same age as athletes but when you get to
be my age I mean you start wearing a
Jersey it's like uh you
know what's going on
everybody
are you his father is he is that why
you're wearing the
Jersey I didn't know he was half
[Music]
white I'll tell you the last jersey that
I would have
worn is uh of someone that was playing
while I was alive not a throwback uh is
Kevin Garnett on the Celtics that was
that was the jersey that I wanted so of
course my mother got me Paul Pierce I
said I wanted Kevin gardet and she goes
you like him I I I like Paul Pierce
better I was like yeah Mom I said I
liked
him well it's still a Celtics
Jersey it's like all right you know
okay um it somehow feels childish to me
okay consequently I Resto I I've
resorted to wearing my sports gear in
private like a crossdresser
I wait for roommates to leave put on my
hat Jersey and tune into the game um
listen there's there there's nothing
wrong with holding on to some of your
childhood I don't even think it's wrong
if you're wearing a jersey I I don't I
don't you know I actually got to be
honest with you I I watched the first
two Bruins games of this year and it's
the their 100th
anniversary I've been watching for uh 43
of those hundred years I started started
watching in
1980 and uh I'm not going to lie to you
I saw in backtack nights they they wore
their they wore white at home which I
haven't seen in forever I mean that was
how it was when I was growing up first
time I went to a Bruins game with Pete
Peters um Rick
Middleton and all of those guys right it
was that Peter
McNab this before we got charliie
simma all those great [__] names
right Terry O'Reilly Wayne
Cashman I think Stan Jonathan was still
on that team I can't remember was a long
time ago but the home team used to wear
white at home um so they they they were
doing a nod to one of their old jerseys
with that had sort of a new look to it
they had the old school Bruins logo and
then the second game against the
Predators came back both times l Che on
the fourth line all of a sudden L cheats
got the soft
hands soft [__] hands since he he he
this guy's just serving him up I mean he
should he he has a couple assists that
guy should have like five assists um and
he keeps hitting pasta on
breakaways it's kind of been like a good
thing where they kind of do like this
overlapping thing where they kind of do
half a line change because he's on the
fourth line passes on the first line but
when they get out there they got kind of
got this chemistry already in two games
but anyway then on the on uh on the
Friday or Saturday Saturday they played
played the Predators they had the black
one and I'm not going to lie to you I
did look at that and see if tried to see
if they had any kids sizes CU I wanted
to get them for my
kids um I actually
have a Bruins hoodie that I bought in
like
19787 or 1988 it still fits me if you
can believe it uh which by the way dude
I'm down to a 3 5 in Waist I was a 32 in
high school but I mean I was like
[__] you know I weighed like 158 lbs
I mean I had to fill out and look like
an adult I didn't want to look like some
[__] guy that had a blood disease you
know so I went up to like a 34 in waist
and I was like okay I'm not getting any
bigger than that and then I don't know
what the [__] happened I think I went up
to like 38 so now I'm down to
35 Oh Billy bpal um my shoulder is
[__] back I'm doing great I did five
pull-ups the other day one two three
four five to quote Bill Cosby um on
stage not off
uh so I'm getting back in shape again I
just got to I just got
to those abs seven and eight you know I
kind of figured out why now when you
become an old man your [__] ass crack
is always hanging out of the back of
your pants it's your [__]
belly what happens is the belly pushes
your pants down when you have a flat
stomach where your belt is it's just
below your navl and then the fatter you
get the further down it goes it ends up
getting down like just above your pube
line so then like every time you take
your shirt off you're already showing
like a [__] inch of ass crack and
that's what ends up happening that's why
women always going like how do guys not
know their asses hanging out on the back
of the pants it's like CU cuz they have
another ass in the
front
um or as I call it my third titty I'm
getting rid of it it's down to a [__]
beup
either call it my third titty or I call
it my uh it's the cheeseburger I just
grab it I mean it's like a [__]
Wendy's Triple Decker right now it's
[__] annoying um so anyway uh he said
a few weeks ago I had an un unexpected
encounter when one of my roommates came
home oh no see you you you're [__] in
the closet and found me fully decked out
in my sports gear I was
mortified this experience has left me
questioning whether it's acceptable for
a grown ass man to wear jerseys in
public or if my insecurity is Justified
I recently came AC well did your
roommate start giving you [__] or is
this all in your head I think you got to
go with your gut dude if you're just
feeling like I shouldn't be wearing this
[__] anymore I mean there's people that
never stop wearing them but if if they
feel I feel like if you are thinking I
look stupid in this [__] you're going to
look dumb in it um this happened to me
like I I they the Mitchell and Ness made
a throwback Fran Tarkington Jersey and
that was my guy in the
70s Roger starback and uh Fran tarington
and I got the the Fran Tarkington and I
put it on and I look like a [__] jerk
off I never wore it I ended up giving it
away on the podcast and you know what I
didn't miss it but I do love Fran
tarington um anyway this experience has
left me questioning whether I recently
came across a a Bleacher Report article
that suggested only two groups of of
people can wear jerseys in public
without judgment children under the age
of 13 and individuals with Down Syndrome
nah come on that's a little that's a
little harsh my question is do you think
it's silly for men to wear jerseys in
public thanks go [__] yourself no I
don't I mean it's definitely a Vibe it's
something that you're putting
out you know
uh I think that you have a problem with
it because you think you're too old for
it and if you think that you should go
with that you know but
uh I think you
know you got to come out of the closet
here this is like a closeted gay man you
got to go live your [__] life and let
people deal with it the same thing with
this it's like what's making what you're
doing weird is that is you're just not
out with it and that's what makes
everybody
uncomfortable
you ever [__] work with some guy and
you just knew he was gay everybody knew
he was gay and it's like can he just say
he's [__] gay like when I was growing
up like you just couldn't do it I must
have told this story before we were
[__] [__] hanging
out we're in this
bar and one of the guys I worked with he
was a nice guy but he was just [__]
gay man and he just wouldn't say it
because he couldn't it was the
80s and we were in the
bar um the [__] 80s so was like that
girl is poison big [__] Z cavari
[__]
pants [__] super loud music right so
all these [__] ladies are walking by
with their hair all [__] up to the
ceiling and [__] you know hairspray
[__] 80s man right the guys got the
[__] the giant torsos and the skinny
pretzel legs right cuz all we did was
upper body
lot of neon and [__] and this [__] I
still remember this chick looked like
she was [__] smoking hot red dress
red pumps walking by all [__] tanned
up she's probably dead at skin cancer
but she was in the prime of her tan and
life and she came walking by it was like
what the
[__] it
was it was just one of those things even
as loud as the music was you just sensed
her coming and she walked by and none of
us had and none of us going to say was
just beyond out of our league but what
you did they would walk by I always call
it the pirate thing like guys turn into
Pirates you know when a beautiful woman
would walk by that you just walk by kind
of give him a nod and then you turn said
right [__] bend her over a [__]
couch he just started so we went in to
do that pirate
[__] and before we did the closeted gay
guy goes that girl was
awesome and it just
killed everything we were going to say
and I just remember uh one of the guys I
work with [__]
hilarious he just brought his beer can
up to his right before he went to take a
sip he looked at me and he did the
eyebrow thing
like now I think that that's what you're
doing with the Jersey you know you got
to come out of the closet or stop
[__] wearing them but you can't only
wear it at home when you're watching the
game then it looks weird now it looks
you might as well be sitting there
holding a teddy
bear
um I think it's cool as for an older guy
to wear a
Jersey from the era when you were a kid
like I love seeing like Rams Fans around
La wearing like Eric Dickerson [__] um
or the really old guys wearing like you
know Deacon Jones or Merlin
Rosie
Greer uh wait who else the Fearsome
forsome was oh [__] I'm not gonna go
down that rabbit hole God damn it Deacon
Jones Rosie
Greer Merlin
Olsen who was the other
guy there's four guys I can't remember
the other one so all right my question
do you think it's silly for men to wear
jerseys in public
um
I think if you're
intelligent you have a certain level of
intellect and a bunch of
interests yeah I kind of think it is I
think it's a little silly but if you're
going to the
game that's
fine like people go to sports bars
wearing their jerseys and [__] I don't
know I mean I think it's a little weird
but but you go over to like [__]
these these soccer countries like they
got like scarves and just all kinds of
stuff they're all singing songs and [__]
so maybe it isn't I don't know I have no
[__] idea I'll just tell you this
okay God made you the way that you are
and you should go out and just be
yourself I don't want you to be in the
closet anymore wearing your jerseys I
want you to go out there and just let
your [__] loyalty to your team be
heard all right Money
Pit hey Bill big fan of the podcast and
your standup well thank you so much uh
saw you a few years ago at the surf in
Clear Lake Iowa yeah I played where
buddy Holley and the big bar per played
and all that did it with Dean Del re it
was amazing uh you know where the Music
Died only thing it's known for haha
literally just said that okay always oh
anyways I've heard you talk multiple
times about your money pit house I have
a house I bought three years ago oh yeah
just it never ends it never ends even if
you buy a [__] new house like once
start stuff starts
going it just it it never ends it never
ends Al
Madrigal one of my favorite people has
summed it up the best owning a house he
said I'm painting the Golden Gate Bridge
that is his reference which and if you
read up on painting the Golden Gate
Bridge uh they paint it in the second
they're done how long it takes by the
time they get to the other side they
have to start over again um anyway he
said I've heard you talk multiple times
about I bought three I bought three
years ago my house okay it's a Victorian
home built in 1908 beautiful woodwork
like you wouldn't believe but it's been
a money pit the likes as I've never
encountered okay before okay galvanized
pipe cloth
wiring uh rodents the stink pipe leading
to the [__] Street if you even have
one fatty AR that one on my [__]
house instead of Fatty Arbuckle's DNA
was took a [__] in there he probably
came over here and did God knows what
right I've had it all dude I've done it
all I've done it all
um since
2011 um anyway 1908 he said uh the first
thing I had to do was get rid of a cart
cartridge house that was on the property
that was falling down next was what is a
cartridge house I would have tried to
save it even if it was completely
useless [__] in love with the past
for some reason uh next was rewiring the
whole thing because it had the old knob
and tube Wire yeah I don't know what
that is but that sounds like cloth
wiring now the city sent me a letter
saying they aren't liable for my sewer
told yeah right here we go stink pipe
from my house because it's so
old yep all that to say oh yeah you know
what that [__] cost
me I'm not even going to say because
people like what the [__] you pay that
much money for cuz I ain't taking a
[__] hold of the sewer you
[__]
oh I could have bought a
[__] sensible car for the amount of
[__] money I spent on that all that
to say do you think I should sell the
damn thing or as you once said
just keep sitting here thinking of
taking a gas can and a match to the
whole place all that all that to say I
do love the homes character but oh Jesus
it's a rough one
um I don't man I I I I would need way
more information I don't know what your
financial situation is I don't know
where you live I don't know what your
options are but I literally look at like
leaving a [__] house because it's
costing you too much [__] money to
then go buy another house that's like
watching people get a divorce
I get you're getting a divorce but now
you're going to go back and get
remarried and think this is going to be
[__] different it isn't it isn't
you're just get you know it's like you
got out of the river and you're just
dragging your [__] raft back up the
same to go back down it again now if you
just completely married the wrong person
I get that but
um I'm the wrong person to ask
because I love fixing up my old
house
um right down to the fixtures the door
handles and all of that I found this
great hardware store that had all of
that stuff and I love that you love an
old house
and I'm only thing I can do is
superimpose myself I don't like the new
[__] I think it's soulless and even when
they try to recreate the other stuff
it's like you
know the craftsmanship the banisters the
stuff the the time that they would take
into doors and windows
and door locks and all of that stuff is
really a lost art and if you can restore
that and
everything
um it's fantastic uh you know the one
thing I've never had the balls to do is
to replace my windows because they're
the original ones and on Windy days it
just blows right through the [__]
house but I just I'm too
sentimental and I know that they make
new more energy efficient ones that look
like the old ones
and
uh I don't know I'll let the next person
do it um so I would hang in there with
the house but I'm a [__] sentimental
fool which by the way I told you guys
did I tell you I I downloaded you know a
bunch of Sam
Cook um Sam Cook's got to be top five
[__] singers of all time he just has
to
be listen to this song I Love You for
sentimental reasons and just the runs
that he does at the you know starting
with like a minute left in the song I
just kept rewinding it going and I
was do this to my lovely KNE all time
I'm was going you listen listen to this
guy listen to She I'm trying to if you
would shut the [__] up I would
um but anyway yeah I am
um I love all old [__] I really do you
know I found a killer video and I posted
it of some guy out here in LA and he hit
me up he had this [__] great old car
I was like a Buick or something from the
1950s
uh this one thing I'm GNA I'm going to
say that I love about Mexicans is how
much they [__] love
cars and and and then and that their
tasting cars too the ones that they
gravitate
towards um a lot of them are the ones
that I like and uh I kind of like but I
I I don't like
uh I like mus you know what muscle cars
are to me it's like wearing a sports
Jersey it's just for somebody young I
just think you know unless I understand
like a baby boom person you know who
didn't have a [__] wanted the car
couldn't afford it when they were a kid
and then they get old and they go back
and get it I get that but I I just feel
like liking muscle cars is kind of
[__] hacky it's like everybody likes
that [__] car you know what I mean
let me give me something different you
know give me one of those old [__]
Thunderbirds where like you open the
door and then like there's this thing
where you know the driver's seat like
totally turned to the side and the
steering wheel goes to the
right you could literally move the
steering wheel that shit's I like I
don't know I'm I'm like that but
whatever the person reached out to me he
said hey you know we'll take you for a
cruise sometime and uh I want to bring
my son cuz my son loves cars and I was
just thinking it'd be so cool of him to
get that experience cuz like my son
literally will see like uh like he loves
trucks he loves cars and all that stuff
and just anything that he
sees he'll be like d Dada police car
police car I'm like yeah police car
buddy and then he's just like I want to
ride police
car I want to ride bus I want to ride oh
green truck I want to ride green truck
it's just it's the best like I I love
that he has that so I kind of want to
take him to some car shows because it
seems like he's going in that
Direction
um anyway girlfriend won't let me wear a
leather
jacket
why hey Bill it's all on the subject
line I'm not sure what she has against
them the one I wear when she's not
around that she won't be seen in public
with me is not some wannabe biker jacket
it's a nice straight cut jacket that
looks good the way I wear it it's not a
tough guy look it's the most basic black
jacket that happens to be
leather uh we've
been together a year and a half and it's
going great that is really the only
thing that bugs me well then just
[__] Let It Go who gives a [__] and
then also if you don't want to be around
her just put the [__] jacket
on you want to go to brunch no do it for
me okay grab your leather jacket on
second thought I'll just go with my
friends I that's you [__] get out of
jail free card
um this is really the only thing that
bugs me what's my move here let me tell
you something if you're with somebody
and a year and a half all it is is she
breaks your
balls about uh your jacket I would just
turn that into like a
joke and like when you want to go do
something I would just grab the jacket
and I go honey honey listen you know
what you put one arm into to sleeve I I
I think I need some alone time if you
know what I mean and he just [__] put
it
on you know I would even do that in the
house if you're in the living room and
you're watching sports and she's
breaking your balls I would have the
jacket behind the [__] couch and I
would just put it on I would just turn
it into a big
joke um so he's saying what's my move
here do I put up a fight or accept
it I've tried finding something wrong
with one of her articles of clothing I
have a few choices but none that are
Hills I'd wanted to die on hey let me
tell you this right now don't ever go at
a woman with how she looks or what the
[__] she's wearing [__] all of that okay
just turn you just turn everything into
like a joke all right and uh but you
know you want to
keep a sense of self in the relationship
where you don't take [__] either but I
don't think this is one of these
situations
um you could also go out and buy an even
even nicer leather
jacket you know and um
I mean there's many ways around this you
could do the joke thing or you could
just be like yeah I get it you don't
like the jacket but you know I like the
jacket I like it but don't ever say Hey
you know there's stuff that you wear
that I don't like and then she'll just
be like what you I don't like those
shoes and she'll be you don't like those
shoes she start doing that it's just
she'll literally and they they don't
[__] see it it's like yeah you get it
you see how this feels this is what
you're doing to me they'll just be like
no it's different that jacket's stupid
my thing isn't stupid there's there's no
[__]
winning any of that [__] this is the
thing you just be nice to him you take
them out you treat them great that's
what you do all right and when they [__]
up you don't yell at them you just it's
silence okay not like you just totally
stop talking to him it just it just it's
Silence with medium energy you're not
happy you're not sad you're not angry
you're not anything you're just [__]
there and you just sit there and you
wait for him to come around that's the
only way to win an argument with the
woman if you want to sit there and try
to [__] you know put a helmet on and
start knocking heads with them you're
going to [__] lose that is an away
game you're never going to win that [__]
okay the thing about women is they have
to feel like they're in [__]
controlled the entire time which is why
they're always talking about how
controlling men are you know it's a
[__] one of the classic misdirections
the fact that women have the [__]
balls to talk about how controlling men
are acting like all of us are walking
around slapping them around like the
good old days it's just that those days
are gone
people [__] with you but it is it's
like most guys you
know I mean look at me I I I have to
play the same [__] game you know I'm
making a great living I'm out here
crushing it but I I still have to play
the same [__] game you have to play
that game never changes you think the
dollar sign no doesn't change doesn't
change now you could marry a [__]
[__] right you can marry a [__] that's
only with you for your money but then
you got all that other [__] you got to
worry about but you actually marry
somebody that you love like that is the
only [__]
way to uh win the argument which is why
I would love to talk to a lesbian and
ask her how do you win an argument with
the
woman all right because Who would know
better than a
lesbian because not
only are they dealing with the same
arguments that you're dealing with as a
straight man because they're in the same
relationship in that they're both you're
both in love with a woman
right but like what I find
fascinating is that she knows the female
moves and she has them simultaneously do
they cancel each other out like the bo
like the
Bose's head you know phones you know
where it's like the opposite frequency
cancels it I don't know what the [__]
I'm trying to say here but I'm just
like I just feel like that's that's like
black belt vers black belt and you're
coming out Victorious where I feel like
as a guy you can do a fight an argument
with a woman it's like you're like a
yellow
belt going up against this master
like what do you want to do you want to
take it to the ground you want to
[__] bring up family members what do
you want to do here I can [__]
destroy you so all right that's my
advice I'm going on and on
here
um you know it's almost Halloween
everybody we're getting into the
holidays again and
uh you know um I want to thank everybody
that's com out to my show I I don't
think I've ever felt luckier in my life
for what my life is not only just
appreciating what my life is but also
just watching what people are going
through with the [__] greed of these
corporations and as much as I'm breaking
it down to politics I think it really
comes down to us like there has to be
some sort of push back here against this
[__] insane level of greed they like
people they they they're getting rid of
the middle class that should just not
happen people should you know if they're
nice enough if somebody is nice enough
and willing to work for your comp which
is your dream not their dream if they're
nice enough to work for you you should
be paying them a wage where they can
live above the poverty line you
shouldn't be trying to figure out ways
to get their kids to work there
instead so their life can go down the
[__] toilet and you can take that
part of the salary and give yourself a
[__] bonus like those people they
they they they just should be
like eliminated from society it's just
making everybody's [__] miserable all
right not to go back to the darkness all
right Billy gochild Rothchild um hey
that's it go [__] yourselves that's the
podcast I will check in on you on
Thursday all right